[Music]
they're looters and rioters
and then you hear the democrats they
never say anything bad about them
even biden in his speech he never
mentioned the words law and order
never mentioned the word police there's
a lot of folks who thought that well the
president's made great strides with his
this this and his you know law and order
strides here that boy after his
convention he really
really made inroads he hasn't
not at all no i'm not sure i'm being
it should give you a little bit of
confidence
in the american people that ain't buying
it
joe biden in kenosha wisconsin today
the family of jacob blake through
attorney ben crump
said vice president biden and dr joe
biden today had a very engaging
90-minute in-person meeting with the
blake family the family was grateful for
the meeting and was
very impressed that the bidens were so
engaged and willing to
really listen they talked about the
changing and disparate treatment of
minorities and police interactions the
impact of selecting
kamala harris as a black woman as a
running mate and vice president biden's
plans for change
it was very obvious that vice president
biden cared as he extended to jacob jr a
sense of humanity treating him as a
person worthy
of consideration and prayer talking
directly to
jacob blake in the by phone let's bring
in our panel charles lane opinion writer
for the washington post
kimberly strassel a member of the
editorial board at the wall street
journal
jonah goldberg editor-in-chief of the
dispatch uh
kimberly your thoughts on the former
vice president's trip to kenosha today
and perhaps the contrast to the
president's trip
yesterday well to me first of all it's
notable that he's
in wisconsin uh and that he's addressing
these issues because those are two
things that the campaign
weren't willing to do a couple of weeks
ago when they had a virtual convention
and they didn't really want to talk
about this subject so
when you change strategy it means that
you are worried in some way
despite joe biden saying that he doesn't
think the president is making inroads on
the law and order thing the fact that
he's out there doing it suggests that
democrats are
worried and we'll see where that goes
but i think it's something that he's
going to have to address
because people keep watching tv and
there's no longer any more denying that
this is becoming a huge
problem in cities and suburban
communities across the country
the trump campaign's response also a
written statement saying joe biden made
a political trip to kenosha today his
first
visit to wisconsin after months of
saying he could not travel because of
the science of the coronavirus
what changed was political science as he
knows he's in a serious decline in the
polls to top it off people participating
in his church meeting kenosha
were handed scripts to read from during
the public comment period
proving again that biden's handlers
don't trust him in uncontrolled
situations
nevertheless americans didn't hear any
denunciation of antifa or any other
left-wing agitators who have rioted in
american cities from coast to coast
said nothing about wisconsin governor
evers acceptance of federal assistance
from president trump to quell the riots
and did not explain that he opposed
calling in the national guard to protect
americans from violent left-wing
rioters joe biden made this above-ground
excursion
from his basement for purely political
reasons and it shows we thought we'd
read both statements uh chuck your
thoughts
well that was certainly a political
statement i mean the president
is not been
emphatic in denouncing uh certain
right-wing people a way
to kind of you know invenuate what uh
because i'll written house did up there
but look
this is i think an effort by
which was as a peacemaker remember
the image he voted at that time was
charlottesville the terrible
violence we thought that was the worst
thing to be
it was that terrible conflict you know
between right and left where
ultimately some of the people on the
liberal side one of them was killed by a
right-wing
person driving a car and so i think this
is
in his view the strength of his campaign
he is viewed as somebody who's
more peaceful more unifying more
stabilizing at least
how he got into this thing i think this
is him taking an opportunity to get back
to the team he started with uh jonah
clearly the law and order issue seems to
be playing in different communities the
president's on his way to pennsylvania
there has been a shift there
but the polls pretty much are the same
place that they have been
uh overall if you look at uh all the key
battleground states
yeah uh look i mean i i agree with both
kim and chuck and different aspects of
this i mean on the one and on the trump
trump campaign statement of course joe
biden is in wisconsin
for political purposes he's running for
president united
states he's not going to travel anywhere
that isn't for a political purpose right
now
and neither frankly is donald trump so i
don't think that lands too hard but
where
i think kim is right is that the law and
order message has some purchase
and not as much as the trump uh campaign
thinks it does
but the simple fact is is that it was
that job was a little slow
in anticipating that this was something
that he would have to respond to and i
actually think
his statements have been pretty good um
on this stuff he's condemning violence
he's not using the language that the
trump campaign wants him to use
uh nor is donald trump using the
language that the dividing campaign says
he should use
and so i think that ultimately where we
are is
this has been one of the most stable
races
in modern memory joe biden's lead has
been remarkably stable
donald trump's base has been remarkably
stable and i really think at this point
the only thing that we can plan on
really shaking the numbers in a
significant way are the debates because
the conventions didn't do it
all right the other news today that
seemed to be a part of the market slide
perhaps was the
the vaccine talk and whether there's
going to be a vaccine at the end of
november
or end of october beginning of november
here is the white house
and tony fauci kimberly
dr fauci said there is no political
pressure that i have seen
at all to move quickly this president
wants to break through regulatory
barriers to get a vaccine as safe
as to the american people as quickly as
possible because lives are at stake
if there is the kind of thing that
people are concerned about
it'll become public sooner or later so i
think that we can
have some confidence and have faith in
what the fda is saying
they're saying very explicitly that
they're going to be making the decision
based on the scientific data
and we hope that that's going to be the
case yeah so the
he's being asked about the fact that
would there be political considerations
in getting a vaccine out
before election day kimberly
yeah so this comes from this theory that
you've been hearing increasingly on the
left that there is political pressure to
rush the vaccine and therefore it will
not be
safe that doesn't take into account the
realities of the fact that the vaccines
have already been
through safety trials you're looking at
questions of efficacy at this point and
how good they are
and is there political pressure to get
this out yes mostly because they're
still dealing with a pandemic and it's
having
a terrible consequence on the economic
and personal lives of millions of
americans
would it be politically good for the
white house to also have it out sooner
rather than later
yes but as dr fauci has said and no one
has provided any evidence
otherwise this seems to be being driven
so far
very much on the scientific merits